one of the insights that I've had in
psychedelic states
is that everything is conscious that
consciousness permeates everything that
you know like I feel whatever and me
that my consciousness is also in rocks
and in plants and animals that there's
some Universal something out there and
it's there are two you know really
different ways of looking at reality one
is the materialist one which of the
consciousness is a product of brain
biochemistry and electricity and that is
dominant in science today the other is
that the brain is a receiving apparatus
for consciousness and that consciousness
is primary
maybe existed before matter may be
organized matter into forms that are
more and more able to experience
themselves I don't know I don't think
there's a way to prove one or the other
it's just that for me the conscious as
the primary one is more fun and makes
life more interesting I'm sure you're
familiar with Rupert Sheldrake oh yeah
he's good friend very very interesting
guy he has an idea that everything has
memory right he believes that that this
would be like the reason I guess why
some people would not want to live in a
haunted house right they would think if
someone was murdered in the house that
it would retain some memory of these
atrocities and that you would somehow or
another interact with that if you were
in that house so like spaces like my dad
is not a very he's not a woowoo kind of
guy yeah but he went to Gettysburg
uh-huh and he was telling me that when
he was at Gettysburg that it just he
felt profound sadness huh
he's like it just seems like it's just
in the ground like the whole area he
goes I don't know how to describe it but
I wanted to get the [ __ ] out of there
huh like just just being around this
area where this battle had taken place
oh so many people had died I said you
could feel it ha
I don't know if I buy I mean but it's
not the kind of guy that know right but
that's an example where you somebody
tells you something that is experienced
I'm willing to entertain it I have to
experience in less yeah but it also
could be you know like he he got lucky
and didn't get drafted during Vietnam
and that's probably in his
had that if he did get drafted he might
have died over there and for what reason
he wouldn't experience this life yeah
you know why what is the person then
thinking about these young men that died
in the same fashion for some war that
didn't make any sense like why the [ __ ]
are they even fighting it like who why
why is it and then having all these
people die together in this one horrible
battle in this one place and he you know
it could have been he was playing a game
on his mind but